et celui-là julie où veux tu que je te
pose quand je réfléchis ici et là je
crois que ça serait bien comme ça eh ben
dis donc ton est halal frein effet fort
visage vous est là quand vous êtes en
avance 5
nous préparons la grande fête annuelle
de l'île aux enfants c'est une kermesse
est pour l'instant
eh bien nous installons aux stands et
cette fois j'aurai vraiment ma boutique
à moi bien encore rien le dernier woody
donc ils ont faut se dépêcher
c'est bientôt l'heure prévue pour le
début de la kermesse voilà là et casimir
qui est pas encore arrivé sur ce stand
sera jamais prêt aucune importance avec
ciba à porter il vendra rien du tout
comme les autres années gentil avec lui
parce que même s'ils n'ont rien c'est
pas une raison de se moquer ouais c'est
vrai c'est pas gentil qu'un regard il à
la caisse
salut tout le monde bonjour je regarde
et j'ai savais pas quoi nos bonnes
choses formidables à vendre au yoyo
regardez garde au sein ça c'est chouette
hein le statut peut le dire c'est même
incroyable vraiment casimir qui auraient
pu faire un effort d'imagination
tu sais bien que c'est une vente
spéciale pour offrir aux enfants de
l'île de nouveau joint oil est alors et
alors où tu achèteras rien que ça wade
j'ai choisi les plus belles choses que
j'avais chez moi oh ouais excuse-moi
casimir h n'aurait pas dû mettre en
colère après tout c'est on sent que tu
as le droit d'essayer de vendre ce que
tu fais qu'est ce que j'ai fait qu'est
ce que j'ai fais la diff de mon ballon
ou la la la la
c'est bien de finir 3 kg j'aime affaire
qui bouge lâchait pas aller mal fixé
hoyé alors alors je crois que toujours
ce bois là ça il pourrait servir à la
cale et ouais d'accord de francs un
petit don c'est vraiment cher
or vois tu sais c'est une vente de
charité un job oui c'est d'accord merci
personne n'a vu la fiche de monbalen
j'ai dû oublier chez moi terrible
diderot casimir bien j'ai oublié chez
moi où j'ai perdu la tige de monde hier
ni ballot ah oui et ce morceau de fil de
fer là qui est devant toi sur ta table
m'arrangerait bien je peux lui un bon
mada coraline merci 201 deux fronts
ouais ben dis-donc tiennent quasiment
merci bonjour facteur cela c'est le fait
qu'ici power ois chaussures bon ben pour
moi c'est pas la fête
donc j'ai cassé la peau un bon sac alors
c'est beaucoup plus fatigant de le tenir
à la main sur l'épaule
pas vrai au quasi me what s arrête cette
ficelle et avant
ouais bien sûr demain à la chambre
achète bien pour vous seuils de francs
bonjour merci facteur exercer le pouvoir
avant l'ouverture pour
quelle merveille n'est ce pas oh je
cherchais justement une sculpture pour
mettre dans mon salon voilà casimir
presque sa tâche est cette merveille et
250 francs ça suffit 260 saba au revoir
monsieur 10 nov ben au revoir et merci
et bonne chance pour dire merci merci
mon jean peeters en bois un moment que
vous aviez raison je ne voudrais rien
pendant la kermesse son corps j'ai tout
vendu
ah bon
[Rires]